notre rendez-vous du mardi soir question
de génération les élèves de la région
posent des questions d'actualité
aujourd'hui nous sommes allés au collège
Thomas divide Châteaudun en Eure-et-Loir
et c'est vous Christine Launay bonsoir
qui répondait ok aux questions des
collégiens on écoute justement cette
première question
je m'appelle Hélène j'ai 14 ans je suis
en 3e Bernard Arnault le milliardaire
français qui a fait un don de 10
millions d'euros au resto du coeur a été
beaucoup critiqué mais pourquoi bah oui
pourquoi pourquoi cette polémique et
bien c'est 10 millions d'euros
correspondent presque au tiers de la
somme dans ton besoin les Restos du
Coeur pour boucler leur budget 2023 mais
pour le milliardaire ce dont correspond
à
0,04% de sa fortune selon nos confrères
de France Info une fortune estimée à 200
3 milliards d'euros selon le magazine
Forbes alors ce dont c'est encore trop
peu pour la France insoumise le deuxième
groupe d'opposition à l'Assemblée
nationale critiquée le milliardaire pour
cet acte de philanthropie la député et
les filles Daniel obono par exemple a
rappelé que si la taxation des
ultra-riches avait été mise en place
Bernard Arnault paierait sa juste par de
l'impôt et qu'il n'y aurait pas besoin
d'en appeler à sa charité alors pour sa
part Bernard Arnault a rappelé lui que
les 10 millions d'euros versés ne sont
pas défiscalisés alors la deuxième
question à présent il est question de du
séisme au Maroc
je m'appelle Orane j'ai 14 ans et je
suis en troisième qui l'aide de la
France n'est pas acceptée par le Maroc
comment il est le Maroc après le séisme
alors oui des secouristes français sont
restés cloués au sol faute
d'autorisation mais sur place des ONG
présentent toute l'année comme le
Secours populaire en t'apporter une
première aide précieuse au sinistrée en
leur faisant parvenir des kits de survie
par exemple la Croix-Rouge française
l'UNICEF et l'ONG se sont aussi
mobilisés très vite en lançant des
appels au don financiers car c'est bien
d'argent dont on besoin les associations
humanitaires les collectes de vêtements
organisés depuis la France sont très
généreuses mais elles sont pour
l'instant suffisantes donc ce sont des
produits de première nécessité dont ont
besoin les sinistrés de l'eau des
médicaments des produits alimentaires
non périssables et détente 300.000 euros
pardon excusez-moi 300 000 personnes
seraient sans abri les collectes
d'argent pourraient servir aussi à la
reconstruction
la troisième question ce sera sur du
rugby
je m'appelle Noah j'ai 14 ans et je suis
un troisième
d'après les premiers matchs de la Coupe
du monde de rugby qui est le grand
favori de cette Coupe du Monde 2023
alors moi j'ai la réponse c'est la
France alors oui la France a remporté le
match d'ouverture contre les Old black
de la Nouvelle-Zélande les Bleus
accueillent la Coupe du monde donc ils
sont favoris puisqu'il joue à domicile
c'est toujours un avantage mais pour
avoir un pronostic un peu plus précis
nous avons fait appel à un chroniqueur
de notre matinale André Deleplace
écoutez alors pour la première année la
Nouvelle-Zélande n'est pas dans le grand
favori il y a plutôt trois équipes qui
se dégagent l'Afrique du Sud qui est en
très grande forme et très costaud
l'Irlande aussi qui est première nation
du monde et puis quand même nous il faut
le dire la France on est en formant
olympique on a le meilleur joueur du
monde alors je pense que les favoris
c'est bien nous pour cette Coupe du
monde